draußen ohne sprache kam plötzlich sah
ich habe gerade mal ein stück gegessen
ich hab hunger und schwarz wir müssen
[Musik]
hey leute was klappt und wir kommen bei
einem neuen wie die yo yo yo ma kulanz
auf jeden fall kann er ungefähr vor
einer woche dieses video von mir
ich bestelle um drei uhr nachts ein
cheeseburger und ich habe gesagt wenn
dieses video innerhalb von 24 stunden
2006 bekommt dann bestelle ich auch um 3
und nachts um eine pizza und irgendwie
war sehr klar alles hat innerhalb von 24
stunden deutlich mehr aktien leicht
geschafft und ich musste natürlich
erstmal mich ein bisschen so wieder
fragen weil das waren ziemlich harten
schlag dann bin ich manchmal abends im
bett und konnten schlafen weil ich immer
diese erinnerung hatte hey was war los
wieder im happy meal ehrlich auf jeden
fall haben wir gerade schon ziemlich
spät nachts und ich fahre auch also wir
fliegen gleich in sieben stunden so
fliegen wir also ich mein bruder
zusammen aus spanien und wir fahren halt
um 5 uhr wegen schlag jetzt gar nicht
und es gerade noch ein kollege von mir
hier und wir haben noch hunger und das
gute ist wir haben hier eine pizzeria
jetzt 14 stunden auffahrt auf jeden fall
warte ich jetzt deshalb 3 dann rufe ich
da an
und dann gehe ich mal davon aus die
priester kommt um 3 uhr schon wieder
richter also ich hoffe ihre freude
stuber schon länger gespannt und
vielleicht besteht ja heute auch da
nicht man weiß es nicht vielleicht
wir haben vielleicht kann ich dir
einfach nur in ruhe essen und wer von
einem verschont aber ich glaube es nicht
okay leute wir haben es 233 als
ungelogen die uhrzeit stimmte ich bei
diesem video sf zwei 33 und ich hoffe
wir kriegen es immer wieder überlegungen
ist einfach anfangen
in jeder hälfte hallo ich würde die
bestellung auch wenn uns vereine liefern
sich noch gern eine familie pizza
margherita danke allah gut war nicht
lustig also ich mach mich jetzt nicht
wahr pizzalieferung okay wir kommen
zurück zum thema wir müssen wieder ernst
bleibe ich glaube jetzt wirklich echt
wir warten jetzt einfach mal bis
klingelt und dann wenn er fort 53
teure super des domes die haben die
nicht mehr geschnitten müssen wir die
schneiden hätte ich vor so weit jetzt
683 dass ich mich jetzt dabei wurde er
gar nicht
was zum 2 1 1 1
konstanz zu interessieren warum tut ja
gerade so wehner
[Musik]
783 alles möglich ist
klasse müssen wir erst mal die
aufschrift und was die augsburger
spieler ausgemacht alter die ganze
schule fügt dem noch vier stücke ist man
sprachlos entwickelt haben einem kurzen
ansprache ganz lässt sich sein reicher
ich habe gerade mal ein stück geklappt
ich hab auch das waren acht stücke dass
wir den rand loszuwerden
aber das hier nicht zu länge von 2 1
hätten herr 13 ja dann die können nicht
weg sein alter ohne spaß als etwas was
geht ja fast schon wieder man glaubt
dass sie auch auf 1 83
[Musik]
deine träume ich konnte ich war kurz
schleifmittel aber teuer es wird
trotzdem noch ein stück ein stück
peterson planbar sein kann sollten sich
mann erlassen jetzt 41
da ist es uns spaß wo es ist letzte
stück kannst du nicht sein und schwarz
wir müssen raus
er musste schlüssel bei 10.000 likes
kommt sich auf
[Musik]